Could you tell me again why a cancer patient should not take glutamine?
My other doctor wants me to take it for my gut.
Well this is a kind of a caution for taking advice from too many people sometimes because
sometimes another doctor is not necessarily trained in taking care of cancer patients.
So this is why I also ask you, you're free to do whatever you want as far as supplements
that you feel like you want to take or avoid other doctors and getting their advice by
all means, go ahead and do all that.
But I think it's a good idea to run it by me like this person did by asking me this question.
My other doctor wants me to take glutamine and I think I remember you saying it's not a good idea.
Well the reason why it's typically not a good idea is because cancer is always trying to find a source of fuel.
Now the first source of fuel for every cancer is going to be sugar breaks down into glucose.
Glucose is going to be the main source of fuel because it is always the main source of fuel for all cells.
Now glutamine is a number secondary source of fuel for all cells on brain cells.
Glutamine can be primary source of fuel for certain brain cells, especially astrocytes.
And your brain can be fueled by cancer.
So certain brain cancers, especially astrocytoma and another possibility is a glioblastoma
or can be fueled by glutamine.
So you have to be careful under glutamine intake.
So why would a person take glutamine?
Why would you be recommended glutamine for the gut?
Because glutamine can help the help replenish and heal epithelial cells quite quickly
because it really up regulates the growth of and reproduction of epithelial cells.
So if you have a cancer, do you want something that's going to fuel growth?
Not such a good idea.
So I wouldn't take glutamine as a supplement to help heal the gut.
There's a lot of other choices out there.
So there's a lot of different supplements that you can do to help heal the gut without having to take glutamine.
So that's why I wouldn't do it.
Is that it up regulates growth?